alors comment ça non non non j'ai un
problème là je crois qu'il faut que
j'aille chez le médecin mais qu'est ce
qui t'arrive
je crois que je suis luxé le cerveau
luxe et le cerveau ouest c'est à dire
quand je trouve la tête trop vite comme
ça là ça me fait mal j'ai mal à la tête
ou quoi oui voilà
[Applaudissements]
nouvelle session de démontage deux
mythes et de mythos sur la santé mais
aujourd'hui on va procéder de façon un
petit peu différente
aujourd'hui on va s'attaquer aux
expressions que tout le monde emploie
mais qui sont fausses et qui ne reflète
pas la réalité voire qui font naître de
fausses croyances
un exemple quand on a des nausées et
qu'on dit qu'on a mal au coeur on est
d'accord que ça a rien de cardiaque
c'est au niveau digestif que ça se passe
voilà c'est ça l'idée alors celle là
elle est évidente mais vous allez voir
qu'il y en a d'autres qui le sont
beaucoup moins
allez c'est parti il a failli avaler sa
langue
allez on commence avec un grand
classique puis sûr que cela voulait déjà
entendu en général ça se passe comme ça
il ya une personne qui perd connaissance
et là quelqu'un qui se précipitent pour
l'empêcher d'avaler sa langue
attention c'est très bien il faut aller
aider les gens qui perdent connaissance
mais personne laval sa langue ni celle
des autres sauf des fois dans le risque
quand quelqu'un perd connaissance et que
tous ses muscles se relâchent et que la
langue c'est un sacré morceau
donc quand on est inconscient et qu'on a
allongé sur le dos les muses de la
langue ils la tiennent plus en place et
la partie là à l'arrière et devient
toute molle elle tombe et elle vient
boucher la trachée donc elle nous
empêche de respirer
donc on laval pas elle empêche l'air de
passer et ça c'est beaucoup plus grave
donc ça sert à rien de vous précipiter
et de mettre vos doigts dans la bouche
pour tirer sur la langue
en plus vous risquez de vous faire
mordre si la personne convulse par
exemple mettez la en pls basculer sa
tête en arrière et ouvrait lui la bouche
ça sera beaucoup mieux je vous remets le
lien de la vidéo sur la pls dans la
description ça peut toujours servir
on l'a plongé dans un coma artificiel
celle là aussi vous l'avez sûrement
entendu mille fois et pourtant ça veut
pas dire grand chose en réalité on
devrait parler de sédation ou de
sédation analgésie
quand on dit qu'on a plongé quelqu'un
dans un coma artificiel
en réalité c'est juste une anesthésie on
peut l'endormir plus ou moins longtemps
et plus ou moins profondément soit pour
l'empêcher d'avoir mal soit parce que
son état est stable soit par exemple
parce qu'on lui a mis un tuyau dans la
trachée pour l'aider à respirer
en gros c'est quand on a un problème de
santé sérieux et que c'est mieux pour
nous qu'on dorme de temps que ça se
passe alors que le coma c'est les
conséquences d'une souffrance du cerveau
ça peut être pour différentes raisons
qui font que on est inconscient et que
malgré les stimulations on n'arrive pas
à nous sortir de cet état c'est vraiment
deux réalités très différentes dans un
cas celui du coma il ya une souffrance
du cerveau donc et l'évolution est
parfois difficile à prévoir
et dans l'autre cas la sédation les
médecins provoque volontairement une
anesthésie prolongé avec des médicaments
donc c'est quelque chose qu'on peut
contrôler et on peut surtout réveiller
le patient dès que son état le permet
donc vous voyez c'est pas pareil alors
avoir un proche à l'hôpital
c'est déjà stressant c'est pas la peine
de faire flipper les gens en leur
parlant comme à caen n'y a pas de
comment j'ai mal aux reins bon là on est
clairement dans la même veine que j'ai
mal au coeur
on se trompe juste d'organes les rats
n'ont généralement rien à voir là dedans
parce que neuf fois sur dix on ajuste
mal en bas du dos bon alors c'est vrai
que les reins c'est par là qu'ils sont
situés mais dans l'immense majorité des
cas c'est les lombaires qui sont en
cause
donc on devrait dire j'ai une lombalgie
vouloir aux lombaires meyrin à lamballe
vous connaissez ce qui fabrique le pipi
c'est possible d'avoir mal aux reins
alors soit dans les cas d'infections
urinaires qui remontent jusqu'à eux
on appelle ça une pyélonéphrite soit
quand ils se forment à l'intérieur des
petits cailloux de calcium le plus
souvent on appelle ça des calculs et ça
donne des coliques néphrétiques ceux qui
ont déjà eu il s'en souviennent en
général c'est vrai que ça fait mal dans
le bas du dos ou un tout petit peu plus
haut mais pas au niveau de la colonne
vertébrale plutôt sur les côtés et
surtout c'est une douleur disons
caractéristiques il est cardiaque
bon là c'est clair ça veut rien dire
cardiaque c'est l'adjectif qui désigne
ce qui se rapporte au coeur donc on peut
dire j'ai une maladie cardiaque
même si en réalité on dit plutôt j'ai
une pathologie cardiovasculaire parce
que ça concerne le coeur mais aussi les
vaisseaux est bon une pathologie
cardiaque d'une maladie du coeur
ça a du sens mais je suis cardiaque
je suis du coeur non quand vous avez la
chiasse on vous dit pas vous êtes
intestinale voilà j'ai une rage de dents
ok donc d'un côté on a la rage et de
l'autre on a les dents deux secondes je
checke dans mon dictionnaire invisible
alors rage maladie infectieuse
caractérisée par un délire furieux avec
impulsion à mordre hockey et donc rage
de dents violente crise de mal de dents
voilà donc le seul rapport entre la rage
et les danses et que les animaux qu'on
la rage ils ont tendance à mordre et que
nous quand on a mal aux dents des fois
on a envie de mordre des trucs ça fait
léger pour comparer une carie à une
maladie mortelle
j'ai une vertèbre déplacée ah oui elle
est belle celle là c'est vraiment
l'archétype de l'expression qui donne
l'impression que ce qu'on a c'est hyper
grave tu as une vertèbre déplacée quoi
pour atteindre un petit point atomique
nos vertèbres elles sont empilées les
unes au dessus des autres pour former la
colonne vertébrale
au milieu il ya la moelle épinière qui
passe avec les nerfs qui sortent sur les
côtés du coup si on déplace une vertèbre
il se passe quoi ça comprime ou sa coupe
la moelle épinière et tout ce qui se
trouve en dessous est paralysé alors ça
peut arriver si on a un accident grave
si on a une fracture vertébrale un truc
comme ça mais on est d'accord que
généralement ce n'est pas de ça qu'on
parle quand on dit j'ai une vertèbre
déplacée dans ces cas là on parle de
cette sensation qu'on a parfois d'avoir
le coup ou de bloquer mais en réalité
c'est juste des contractures des petits
muscles de la zone qui empêche les mises
habituel et la vertèbre ll est toujours
à sa place
faut arrêter de dire ça c'est flippant
perdre les eaux je me permets juste un
petit aparté pour préciser un truc qui
m'a fait pas mal philippe et quand
j'étais petit le jour où ma mère quand
elle était enceinte m'a dit qu'elle
allait perdre les eaux moi ça m'a
terrorisée
parce que j'étais persuadée qu'elle
allait devenir comme ça donc on est
d'accord qu'une femme quand elle va
accoucher elle perd pas les eaux de son
squelette
elle perd le liquide dans lequel le bébé
a baigné pendant la grossesse parce que
la poche dans laquelle il y avait tout
ça elle s'est fissurée et ça c'est le
signe que la suite va pas tarder à
arriver
alors il ya encore plein d'expressions
qui trompe sur la marchandise et le plus
souvent elles donnent l'impression que
les choses sont beaucoup plus graves
qu'elles ne le sont en réalité comme un
rhume de cerveau par exemple si juste un
rhume en fait le cerveau a rien à voir
là dedans laissez le tranquille on n'a
pas toutes les faire mais avant de
partir je vous en donne une petite
dernière quand j'ai la migraine avec le
poney et la piscine c'est l'excusé la
plus utilisée pour pas faire toutes
sortes de choses qu'on a pas envie de
faire puis la migraine sa claque pour
connaître ça donne l'impression que
c'est un truc sérieux et pourtant dans
la grande majorité des cas ces employés
pour parler juste d'un simple mal de
tête
alors attention assez chiant d'avoir mal
au crâne mais la migraine
c'est pas ça enfin c'est pas que ça
c'est beaucoup plus complexe
c'est même tellement complexe que ce que
je vous propose c'est que on en reparle
très bientôt dans une vidéo début oui et
d'ailleurs on a pas mal au crâne
le crâne c'est les eaux s'est rarement
les eaux qui font mal ainsi on peut
quand on a eu un traumatisme crânien par
exemple mais là encore on est d'accord
que quand on emploie cette expression
c'est ça qu'on parle
ce qui fait mal en général c'est les dso
les nerfs les structures du cerveau et
encore une fois on reviendra là dessus
dans une prochaine vidéo parce que la
migraine joue jure c'est parce que vous
croyez
voilà dtc c'est fini pour aujourd'hui on
se retrouve très vite pour des nouvelles
vidéos d'ici là prenez soin de vous
prenez soin les autres fait un petit peu
attention à ce que vous dites
mettez vous bien et surtout
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]